the royals take on the tigers in game
three of this four game series matthew
boyd the lefty deals wit swings knocks
it to right field and that ball is going
to find the gap there will be at least
two with racing for second
and he will hold there with a double
salvador perez
swung on hit high in the air
center field playable for jacoby jones
he makes the catch
with tags heads to third and he is there
safely
michael franco
and a ball hit to the right side and
that's a base hit
whit merrifield will score franco
hustles to second base he is there with
a two base hit royals manager mike
matheny told us that danny duffy needed
to give us some innings tonight the nico
goodrem fastball swung on and missed
jonathan scope is the batter
ooh
change up in a
perfectly located spot miguel cabrera
the o2 pitch swung on and missed he
struck him out so danny strikes out the
side he looks outstanding in the bottom
of the first inning
alberto monteci set to lead off
and there's a swing and a drive in the
left center field alley and that ball is
over the head of jacoby jones and here
goes modesty flying around second not
stopping there the throw to third is
[Applause]
not in time oh
he just stayed on the bag it appears so
now bubba
that's lined to left field and getting
behind it is stewart
mondy tags
and this throw will come in late
and now they have one in the second for
a two-nothing lead danny struck out the
side in the first inning he comes set
brings the 2-2 pitch to krone swung on
and missed he struck him out
now christian stewart
fastball right there outside corner at
the knees danny duffy with five
strikeouts
and now michael franco with two on and
one out 2-1
and there's a ground ball through the
hole on the right side a base hit whit
merrifield
will be waved around third here he comes
home and he will score it's an rbi base
hit by michael franco and now ryan
mcbroom
jammed him but that's going to be down
for a base hit
solaire scores
franco stops at second and ryan mcbroom
makes it four-nothing royals in the
third inning jacoby jones with a runner
at first base
jones turns on one to left and that ball
is up against the wall grinder will dig
for third he'll be held there and jacoby
jones on cue
with a no out double here in the third
jonathan scope
scope sends one to center
right center
marifield's got it
griner is going to score and the tigers
are on the board
here in the third
and c.j krohn will lead off the tiger
fourth inning open stands for the right
hand batter the one two swing and a miss
as duffy went up with a fastball above
the zone jamer candelario pitch fastball
swing and a miss in on candelario and
danny has his seventh
strikeout grayson grinder duffy comes
set brings it swung on and miss struck
him out on the chain jump eight
strikeouts for danny so now the tying
run will come to the plate in nico
goodroom
fly ball to left
cordero's got it at the warning track
reyes tags so does jones
tigers have cut the lead in half here's
jonathan scope
goes the other way i got it deep to
right merrifield's back
leaps and it's gone scope did it again
a two-run blast to even things at four
and he got enough of that i i thought it
could have a chance right off the bat
you see meritfield jumps and couldn't
jump quite high enough
good night so far for jacoby jones
another 3-2
this one sprayed the other way that
one's deep that ball's gone jacoby jones
pushes the tigers in front it's now 5-4
as he wears a crown again on a wednesday
night to lead the tigers hitting attack
there's the number nine hater nikki
lopez two away the 1-1
pop-up
goodrum is under it
he's got it and a feel-good
come-from-behind win for joe jimenez and
the tigers down 4-0 at one point they
score five unanswered
scope and jones with homer's jacoby
jones with a game-winning shot